>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Hi.
My name is Larry Appelbaum
from the Music Division here
at the Library of Congress.
It is with great pleasure that I'm
joined by one of the great singers
of our time, Grammy award winning
vocal artist, Dianne Reeves.
Dianne --
>> Diane Reeves: Hi.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Great to see you again.
>> Dianne Reeves: Glad to be here.
Thank you.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
You're here in Washington
and here at the Library
to give a performance tonight that's
sort of focused on Ella Fitzgerald
because it's her centenary year.
>> Dianne Reeves: Right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Let's start --
why don't you talk to us about
how you pay tribute to Ella
and still stay true to yourself.
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, that's
the only thing that you can do
because Ella did it in a certain
way that is uniquely here,
and the greatest lesson
that I learned
from here was to beat yourself.
So the thing that I love about her
and people always say it is
the whole joy of singing,
and I think tonight's performance
will celebrate her joy, her courage,
her ability to just jump off the
edge and create in the moment
and be a co-creator
with her musicians.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Are you going
to delve into her repertoire?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
A lot.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And is
there an aspect of her career
that you're particularly drawn to
because she had different stages?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
I think -- when I was in high school
is when I really had the opportunity
to listen to her, and
that was in the 70's.
I was working at this club
that she came and performed at.
And all my life, I had heard Ella.
Of course -- played -- everybody
was playing their favorite songs
and favorite eras of Ella.
But the thing that I
loved was when I saw her,
she was swinging the Beatles tunes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Dianne Reeves: And I thought
that was the most incredible thing
because now that meant
that it's open.
That said to me you know, the
music that you love is the music
that you can bring a
jazz sensibility to.
And that's exactly what she did.
And so for me, that Ella, that thing
about Ella was the
greatest discovery
and the thing that ignited me.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You
actually subbed for her.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: For at least
a few days at The Warehouse.
>> Dianne Reeves: The one
day, it was just one day.
>> Larry Appelbaum: One day?
Okay. Tell that story.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
Well, this is that same performance.
The Warehouse was a club in Denver
that upstairs was the
big club, The Warehouse.
And then downstairs
was The Tool Shed.
And I ended up getting this gig
because Jean Harris had come
through Denver along
with Blue Mitchell.
They were all hanging out in Denver,
and he found a home at this club,
and he would have a
jam session on Sunday.
So I would go to the jam session
and ended up getting a gig there.
I'm in high school.
My parents are chaperoning.
I'm seeing all the
big acts upstairs,
and then they tell
me Ella is coming.
So they made arrangements so
that I could go up and see her.
So I'm watching her show and once
again, she was swinging the Beatles.
And it was just unbelievable,
and went backstage and hung
out in her dressing room,
and people were coming back.
And she was very gracious, and
every time I would get up to leave,
she'd tell me to just sit there.
And finally when everybody left
and she asked me how
did I like the show?
And I told her, that it
was absolutely wonderful,
but I was so star struck and in awe
because while she was being nice
to all of these people, I'm looking
at all this wardrobe and gowns
and shoes laid out and going
my God, it was just a lot.
All these colors and the
tone of her speaking voice.
And so the next night she
was to come, but as you know,
Denver has got a --
we have thin air,
and the air took its toll on her.
And she wasn't able to perform.
So they put a group of musicians.
My uncle is bass assistant.
He was one of them, and he
said we want you go to upstairs
and sing a few songs with the band.
And I remember they hadn't
cleared out her dressing room,
and I was sitting in
her dressing room,
and she had these cute little
periwinkle blue pumps just
sitting there.
They were patent leather, and
I just stuck my feet in them.
They were narrow, but I got my
feet in them, and I remember going
and I performed three songs.
I vaguely remember that because
the entire time I was looking
down at the shoes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: That's hip.
Do you have a sense
from watching her --
I mean, we all know what
a great artist she was
as a singer, as an improviser.
Do you have a sense
of her personality?
What kind of person she was?
Like off the band stand?
>> Dianne Reeves: No.
I mean, only the little
bit that I was able to peep
and I found her speaking voice to
be as I remember it was very small
and like I said, it was kind
of on breath and just gracious
and thank you and da,
da, da, like that.
And I look back, I think knowing
what I know about singing now,
I know that the stage is a
sacred place, and it is a place
that when you walk onto it,
there's an immediate change.
And there is no inhibition.
There is no editing.
There is no fear.
But right before you go on,
you feel all of those things.
You feel -- at least I do -- and
I had heard that she was very,
very nervous a lot of times
before going on stage,
and I thought I understand that.
So the ability becomes a
kind of armor and a shield,
and people see you in a certain way,
and that's how they think of you,
but they don't really know
you, and I know that's true.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
So much of what you do
on stage requires being
in the moment.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Can you
prepare to be in the moment?
>> Dianne Reeves: The
preparing comes from the doing.
That this is a landscape that
you understand and you know how
to navigate and that
you are familiar
with in every fiber of your being.
You know how to hear.
You know what certain harmonies
sound like and how they move
and where you want to go in that,
and so those things
become second nature,
and then the next thing is
what does the moment say
that I should do right now?
It's like this conversation you
could ask me the same question
tomorrow and I will probably
describe the same thing
in a different way.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
We talked about Ella,
but I want to focus a bit on you.
You're born in Detroit.
When did your family move to Denver?
>> Dianne Reeves: When I was two.
I was very young.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So no
memories of Detroit really?
>> Dianne Reeves: No, other than
that's where I spent all my summers,
but basically I did not
attend school there.
I didn't really grow up there.
I grew up in Denver, Colorado.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Music around the house?
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh my God, yes.
I mean --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Was
there a piano in the home?
>> Dianne Reeves: Piano
in the house.
I had my grandmother's sister
-- two sisters and an uncle,
they were all performers,
and the oldest brother
and sister I never met, but
always heard stories about them.
But my one Aunt Kay, that was
when we'd have holiday dinners
at her house, she played and she
would sing all of those Ma Rainey,
Bessie Smith blues with a dual
meaning and adults would be laughing
and we didn't know why
they were laughing,
but I would learn the songs
because it sounded like [crosstalk].
And I remember my uncle would play
bass and so that was one side of it.
Then my uncle was with the symphony
so we would go and hear him.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
This is Charles Burrell.
>> Dianne Reeves: Charles Burrell
and then my mother had her music.
My father loved jazz music so he
-- there were records everywhere
and I think the first cuss word
that I could really say out loud
without a problem was Bitches Brew.
And then of course George Duke and
my sister's ten years older than me
so I'm listening to the
music that she listened to.
Everybody loved music.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
George Duke is your cousin?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
George Duke is my cousin,
was my cousin.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you
remember the first record you bought
with your own money?
>> Dianne Reeves: No because
they were always just --
>> Larry Appelbaum: I mean, what
kind of music were you listening
to when you were preteens?
>> Dianne Reeves: Preteen
-- you know what?
I actually do.
The first record that I bought
with my own money was Marvin
Gaye's What's Going On?
Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh really?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah
because that was different.
But as a kid, here we are, we're
listening now black radio has come
into view in Denver, and I remember
it was a station called KDKO,
Dr. Daddyo, and that's when we
started hearing the music of Motown.
And my nextdoor neighbor
was also from Detroit.
She spent a lot of time like I
would sometimes would go together
to Detroit in the summertime, and
learn all the dances, learn --
and then we'd have -- we had
45's like -- I think my mother,
I'd say I want this 45, and
she would go and she had her --
and my friend, Regina, had her
brother who would bring the 45's
and so we would just listen
to them over and over.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did you
ever sing into your hairbrush?
>> Dianne Reeves: No.
We didn't sing into a hairbrush.
We actually watched -- and this
is a really interesting thing --
we would watch on television
like The Temptations
or when they did the show
TCB with the Supremes,
and I mean we could take all that
in and actually turn back around
and basically do just what they
did, the moves and everybody, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Slick stuff.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah, and so we
would have our own little dances
and stuff, but we sang out
loud, didn't have a hairbrush.
But just had a broom, did all the
different things, could turn around
and grab the broom and
all that kind of stuff.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Were you also
listening to like Stacks records
or was it strictly Motown?
>> Dianne Reeves: No, it
was really everything.
James Brown was very
much a part of my life.
Stacks was a part of my
life because of my sister.
So it was everything.
And it was an interesting
time because in the 60's
and 70's music was very message,
early 70's very message oriented.
So it really could easily be the
background music or the sound track
of your life because all of these
musicians we're talking about,
how we have to come together and
get along and he's not heavy,
he's my brother and
all of these things.
And I remember going to the
record store with my Dad.
The music was in alphabetical
order so that was really cool.
And I think back, there were no
boundaries and wasn't categorized.
I'd never heard the
word genre at that time.
My world music experience before
that word was even coined came
from jazz musicians, listening
to Dizzy Gillespie and the music
of [inaudible] or listen
to Wayne Shorter
and hearing this amazing sound
from Brazil with Milton [inaudible]
and all of this introducing
us to this world of music
and my sister going to concerts
and saying who was there
and it would be all -- you
could be miles [inaudible],
it was just music to people.
So it was really big
and broad at that time.
So what happened when you
first encountered Betty Carter?
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh my God.
I had my own group by this time.
I had moved to Los Angeles, and we
were performing and trying to --
our group was a group
that you wrote a range,
you improvised and
tried to go so far.
We didn't care about coming back,
just see where we could
take the music.
>> Larry Appelbaum: What
was the name of that group?
>> Dianne Reeves: It
was called Night Flight.
And I remember we would always
go and hear different people
that were coming in
town at the time.
I was living way out in Glendale.
My drummer called me and
said, "Dianne, you got to get
down here and hear this lady.
Her name is Betty Carter.
You got to come here.
We just heard the first set.
Come so you can be
here for the next set."
So then you just did that.
Jumped up, made the 45 minute
trek, got there in enough time
to hear her, and I was mesmerized.
I was -- I almost lost my mind.
I'd never ever heard anyone
stand in a band like that.
And really co-create in a way
that the movement of the music,
the musicians would play and she
would pull so far back on the time
and you would think oh my
God, something's going on,
but you knew it wasn't wrong.
It was all right.
And she's telling these
stories with broad strokes
and there was something
about her that --
and I think this happens with every
young artist, that you see a glimpse
of something, that you
actually recognize.
And it's like a fleeting
light, but it's enough
to not only change your
heart and your mind,
but really make you
feel things physically.
And I remember that when I drove
home, I was basically in a trance
because it was like a
God experience for me.
So at the time, I had two roommates.
One was a hairdresser and
one was a flight attendant.
And they were both gone
for the weekend now,
every night now from now on.
That was the first time
she was doing six nights.
So I'm going every
single night to hear her.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
What club was it?
>> Dianne Reeves: Hop
Sings out on Lincoln.
And so I go and I look up
her records at Tower Records.
They are records on Betty Carter,
and I'm going wow,
that's her own level.
And buy a whole new
turn table and set it
up with speakers underneath
it, and this whole weekend,
this whole time my roommates were
gone, when I wasn't at the club,
I'm listening to her with flowers
on either side of the turn table.
I mean, it was like an altar.
And they came home and
they said, "What is wrong?"
I'm like you don't understand.
So I remember the whole band, we
were all there every single night.
And it was -- I believe it was
Curtis Lundy was on -- almost --
I think that [inaudible].
I'm thinking it was [inaudible].
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Yeah, that was a trio.
That was one of our great trios.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah,
was on piano.
But anyway, I remember I thought
okay, I want to try this thing
with these long strokes and
pull back on the time and I said
so I'm going to count off this
slow temple for the man I love,
and you guys just play it.
I'm going to try it.
One, two, three, four.
By the end of the song, I
couldn't find the man I love.
He couldn't find me,
but what an experience.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's
harder than it looks.
>> Dianne Reeves: Well,
but the thing was,
I had a place where I could try.
And so I just kept trying until I
found this place that I liked for me
that worked for me, and I've been
pulling back on time ever since.
The next person I heard do that
in a totally different way was
Shirley Horn.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
Her -- very creative use of space.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Yeah, here in Washington.
Now when you have these kind of
experiences that open the doors
for you in your mind, do
you talk to the artist?
Did you talk to Betty?
Do you talk to Shirley?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
As a matter of fact, Betty from that
point on anytime she came to L.A.,
I was there, but I
hadn't talked to her yet,
and she [inaudible]
know I was there.
And her assistant told
me one time she said --
Betty would say that
girl is out there.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah, stalking.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah, just
listening because it was just --
because from there she went to the
[inaudible] and she also did --
there was another little place,
Vine Street where I saw her.
And it was really an amazing thing.
It was like school.
I call these living schools because
I really got to really sit up under,
listen and break things
down or go oh wow.
I never would have thought to
make a choice like that or playing
with time and making time your
own and being able to take a lyric
and paint a picture with a
lyric and all of these things.
And so I went to the University of
Colorado but I never had schooling
like when I would go and sit
in front of people like her.
I'd go and see Carmen McCray
would be at the Parisian Room.
They're right there.
Big Joe Turner.
I had just broken up
with my boyfriend.
Big Joe Turner was sitting
on stage, and the whole --
my friend took me and I weeped
[phonetic] the whole time
and the whole time he
looked at me and sang.
And it just was this amazing thing.
So those for me -- and being
able to work with a lot
of the architects of the music.
For me, the living school was
the best because you realize
that there was this
intimate exchange that goes
on between musicians, sometimes
jokes but always conversation.
Always taking a conversation
to different levels
and making statements within
the music that audience hears
but doesn't really,
really know where it came
from because the statement
really came
from what just happened backstage
when everybody was
laughing and talking.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You can
learn a lot from reading books.
>> Dianne Reeves:
Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You can
learn a lot from studying scores.
But it's still -- so much of this
music is still an oral tradition.
It's passed on from master to
student or apprentice or whatever.
So when you finally gathered
the courage to talk to Betty
or to Shirley or to
any of the other greats
who inspired you, what
would you ask them?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, I'd
just go there, sit and talk.
I wouldn't really talk about
the music, just listen to --
because Betty was the one
that took over a conversation.
So it was cool with me.
It's like oh, okay.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Was
she curious about you?
>> Dianne Reeves: Later on.
I did this record called Art and
Survival, and Javon Jackson right
after that was doing a record
and he had asked Betty
to produce his record.
And he asked me to be on
it, and I loved Javon.
He's from Denver, and I was
like absolutely and absolutely
because Betty was producing it.
And I think one of the songs
was I Waited for You, whatever.
So I made sure -- I
mean, I knew everything.
I sang it down, and I
remember after the first take
because I just wanted it to be
right and I really thought it out
and really rehearsed, I mean really
rehearsed in a way that it was part
of my show so that it felt like
I could do anything with it,
and then it was just silence.
And I was like oh, God.
She said, "When you
do the second verse,
just be a little more inventive,
just do something else."
I was like, oh, okay.
And I did that.
And our conversation was
really, really short.
I did the song.
She said, cool, cool.
So a couple of weeks later,
I was talking to Bruce
Ludball [assumed spelling],
and I was like I have this idea
for this record, and I wanted --
because I liked the idea of
a woman producing jazz music
because it's a whole different
way of looking at things.
And at the time, I was thinking her
and early on Terry, Lynn Carrington
because she produced
one of the songs
on the Art and Survival record.
And myself, and I thought maybe not
the whole thing but some things.
So Bruce went and told her Dianne
wants you to produce her record.
I was like, Bruce I didn't say that.
So anyway, we ended up talking.
And I said well, I told her my idea.
And she said, "Well if I
don't produce the whole thing,
I don't produce."
I said I'm really sorry
to hear that.
And so we got into this
really deep conversation.
Betty was hard.
And she said, "And
then I heard your -- ."
So I knew she was listening
to my music
because she was calling off tunes.
"I heard you sing Body and Soul,
and I never put anger in my music.
It felt angry and you can't
bring that to audience."
I said, "Well, that's how
I feel about the song.
It was more -- it was
not so much anger
as it was I was stating the
fact that this was where I was.
And I was shouting it.
And I got the courage to do
that from listening to you."
Totally flipped the conversation.
So she said to me, "Look, I have a
run to make and I'll be right back,
and I'm going to call you again."
And I said okay.
And she called me back and
then we started to talk.
And it was -- it was incredible
and after she was diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer,
I remember she was
at the [inaudible] Jazz Festival,
and I went to go see her there,
and we hugged, and I told her that
I really respected and loved her
and thank you for the
performance that evening.
And she gave me this really
wonderful hug and told me
to just be strong out there.
She said stick to who you are.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I'm not
sure there was anybody stronger
than Betty Carter.
>> Dianne Reeves: I don't think so.
Well --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Especially
when you think of when she came up.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah,
but you know [crosstalk].
But Sarah was.
They all had -- they all went
through some -- and Carmen McCray.
They all -- they're all from the
-- cut from the same cloth I think.
Just a different way of dealing
with it, pushing through because --
and I realize that
-- I'll never forget.
I had this gig out at USC once.
And it was with my band, all
my music, and Billy Childs was
in the band at that time,
and we were performing
and this big radio
disc jockey was there
because it was a live
performance on air.
And he decided he would
interview Billy, which was cool.
And so he's like I'm
listening to music.
He's talking about the
music, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he said so who's
the chick singer?
And Billy said, "Oh,
that's Dianne Reeves."
And we've been working together
and da, da, da, da, da, da.
Disc jockey says, "Well,
who's the leader of the band?"
And Billy looks at him and
says, "The chick singer."
So this kind of thing -- the --
what I got from having to
push through was nothing --
I realized was nothing like how
Sarah and Carmen and Ella and all --
Billy and all of them pushed
through in a way that allowed --
for them, it was black
and white, and I got to be
in a gray area if I needed to be.
They created that for me.
But it was still very
male dominated art form.
However, they were really, really
good people like Clark Terry
and Lou Belson [assumed spelling].
Of course, Fat Jones
and Mel Lewis who --
that was the first time I even heard
Dee Dee Bridgewater was with them.
They were open and broad and
hearing music for what it was.
So I had this opportunity
to come through all of that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You led
your own groups for many years.
But you've also worked
for other leaders.
What do you think makes
a good leader?
>> Dianne Reeves: Just being
very, very clear about what it is
that you want and also being
respectful of who you're bringing
to the table because everybody has
a way -- has something to contribute
and they want to make your
thing happen but they do it
in their own voice, and I like
when people are like that.
I learned that Ellington
was like that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: How
did you learn to improvise?
Did it just come naturally?
>> Dianne Reeves: No.
Yes and no.
I mean, the desire of course was
natural but then I had to go --
I ha to learn how to sing
through chord changes
and what to hear and how to hear.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did you do that
just by listening to great singers?
>> Dianne Reeves: Listening
-- yeah, mostly listening.
Listening to mostly instrumentalists
because there was more
instrumentalists
who were improvising
than there were singers.
I mean other than Ella who
was an instrumentalist.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And which
specific instrumentalist would have
inspired you?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, for
different reasons, different ones
like for instance, I loved
Miles because I equated Miles
with after I discovered Milton
[inaudible] with the same kind
of thing with tone, being able to
sing these really beautiful notes
that are on the edge
without bravado.
Just straight and there's a kind of
innocence to the sound or it just --
it cuts through but it --
you want it to penetrate.
Then I'd listen to someone
like Cannon Ball Adderly
[assumed spelling]
who I could hear the
stories in what he played.
So you're listening to Country
Preacher which I recorded,
and you could hear this whole
story of what was going on.
And I love the sound of his
horn and I love what he did
with Nancy Wilson, how well and
how beautifully that went together.
So it would be like that.
Those were the first two.
And then later on when I
discovered the Sarah Vaughn
and Clifford Brown album,
then it was like oh, okay.
This is something --
something else that is --
so I started to realize
that I had to define --
through musicians I
started to realize
that improvisation was one thing but
defining and refining your own sound
and tone was quite another.
And so I went about doing
that because I noticed
that with Sara she really
understood her entire instrument.
Ella created a language to improvise
with, that was strictly for her.
I always tell people that was a
language to be able to articulate
and say what -- reach the
things that she needed to say.
Everybody's different.
Depending on where you
come from, you have to --
somebody who is learning to do
that and they're from Brazil
or something, they're going to
use different kinds of sound.
So you have to find your own place.
And then I found that improvisation
was steeped in phrasing.
While Betty was a great
improviser in terms of with melody
without lyric, but she
also phrased in a way
that was very, very powerful.
Same thing with Billie Holiday.
So how do you want
-- these things began
to help me understand well how
-- what do you want to say,
how do you want to say it and
how will you go about saying it?
So tearing down the songs and
looking at the lyrics and say oh,
I want to say it like this because
this song reminds me of whatever
in my life, and that
would be the subtext.
And then from that point on, just
hearing how the harmonies fall
and knowing where you want to
start and where you want to get to
and you get -- you think farther
than where you are so you know
where you want to get
to at all times.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Interesting
to hear you talk about sound.
And I'm always curious how much
of either an instrumentalist
or a vocalist sound is conscious
and how much of it is --
for example, when we were
just using our speaking voice,
if you're an actor or actress,
yes, you've trained your voice
to sound in a certain way.
>> Dianne Reeves: Right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Most people
just speak because they learn
from their parents or
they learn somehow.
It's not necessarily conscious.
>> Dianne Reeves: Right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So as a singer,
how much of your sound is conscious?
Something that you've
trained yourself to do?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well,
for instance,
speaking because my
instrument is something I have
to use every day on the phone.
I consciously do not
holler into other rooms.
I consciously stay supported
to the point where it's --
keep my voice lifted to the point
where it's just second nature
because I know I have to.
When I have to project -- like
if I have to say something loud
so somebody hears or even in anger,
I'm really conscious about all
of that because I still
know that I have to work.
And also I know the
limitations of my instrument.
I know that my instrument
needs sleep.
I know my instrument needs water.
I know that my instrument
sometimes needs silence.
Needs a smoke-free environment.
But I know singers that
can do all of that,
and they don't have a problem.
But that's their instrument.
So -- and then after that, when I
look at different songs that I sing
because I sing all kinds of music,
different music has a different kind
of atmosphere or sound
scape or landscape.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Give me an example.
>> Dianne Reeves: Like if I sing
say Love for Sale and I do it
in this Brazilian kind of
way, there's a certain way
that I would use my voice.
But if I were to take Love
for Sale and say, you know,
I'm going to bring it down, and
it's really up tempo and fast pace
and it's a lot of fun,
what if I want to do it
in a different kind of way?
I might change the key to bring it
-- if I want to do it as a ballad.
I decide what it is that
I want to say with it.
Might change harmonies that give
my voice a whole another kind
of feeling.
All of these kinds of things to set
up the sound to give the lyric life.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Of course it
helps that you've been working
with certain musicians for
a long time in your band,
whether it's Peter or Romero --
because they're right
there with you.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So you
can change in the moment.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah, and
that's the thing that I love
because they come from
a period of time
where they're real open to that.
So that conversation
thing can happen.
If I'm doing something with Romero
which I'm excited tonight to perform
with just the two of them
because things change and Romero,
if I do something with
just him, I just never know
where he's going to
go, and I love it.
It's the same thing
with my bass player.
I'll turn around with him
sometimes and say okay,
we're going to do all blues.
That's like you pick the groove.
We're not going to
do the traditional.
And every night, but he comes out
of this tradition in New Orleans.
>> Larry Appelbaum: That's Reginald.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
Reginald Veal [assumed spelling].
He comes out of this tradition
from New Orleans that is that,
that in the moment
creates and is comfortable
with the creation they make.
So this goes on all
the time, written --
I wrote this song called Tango just
so that we just have
this opportunity
that every night this
song just changes.
I tell the audience that
it'll never be tomorrow night
or any other night.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So when you're
thinking about a recording project,
you can see where you're
drawn to certain songs.
By the way, what does
draw you to certain songs?
>> Dianne Reeves: It's
mostly the lyric.
Yeah. It's mostly the lyric.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is
that a matter of the story?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah,
and something --
even if I've never experienced
it, there's something about it
that speaks to me so that's --
or something I want to talk about
or that I've seen that
I'm inspired by.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So let's
say you develop a set list
or a program list say ten songs.
Do you then go out on the
road before you record just
to see how the song
sort of takes shape?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah,
yeah absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And how does it
change from your original conception
to what you end up recording?
>> Dianne Reeves: It just does.
That's a really -- it's a
kind of -- it's a funny thing.
Say I'll take for instance
he's doing --
there's this Annie
Defranco song that I do
for my record that never was that.
The way that we recorded
was not how it started out,
and Annie Defranco --
it's called 32 Flavors --
Annie Defranco writes poetry.
So you can interpret it
and she wrote the song
that there's not much of a melody.
So it's really -- it gives itself --
lends itself beautifully
to improvising.
So I learned the lyric, learned
her melody and then I would go
out on the road say like
when I was doing Two Guitars
with Russell Malone and
Romero and I say okay,
we're going to come
up with this groove.
And they'd start this groove.
And then I start putting this
lyrics in certain rhythm on top
of it, and they would respond.
So okay, now we got this thing that
has this kind of middle eastern kind
of drone to it, and it's working.
Okay, we did that.
Then another night it just kept
changing to something else.
And then it turned into a blues and
then it -- I just let it -- I --
going back to what I said earlier
about you know what certain
people bring to the table.
In my band, I know
how all of them are.
So I can look at my drummer
and say okay, do this,
and he will play certain
things that I know
that this is going to work out over.
So it just keeps -- I
just keep trying things.
And that's with a lot of songs.
Keep trying things until we
settle and find a place for it.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Are you
self-critical as an artist?
>> Dianne Reeves: After I've
done it, after I go and listen
to the end product,
then I'm like oh.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I mean,
when you're listening to takes.
What goes through your mind?
>> Dianne Reeves: I
have to really --
the biggest thing is
I have to really --
one thing that George taught me is
when we first started
working together, George Duke,
on my first Blue Note album,
he realized that I was very,
very critical and was like no.
He said you can't -- there comes
a point where you just have
to just walk away because you
are going to be so critical
that the initial spirit, the
initial idea that you just sang
without thinking which is
the real thing will be gone.
And I thought okay.
So I would go in and I would
listen to a take and say okay,
okay and then walk away from it
and come back and hear it in --
and the next day it would hear --
I'd hear it in a totally
different way.
And it's like yeah, keep that.
So I started to really
enjoy my choices,
but sometimes it's
really, really hard.
And then at the very
end, I'm like oh.
I have a hard time
listening to myself.
>> Larry Appelbaum: As a producer,
was George a first take kind of guy/
>> Dianne Reeves: First three takes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: First three?
Because after that you might get
perfection but it's [crosstalk].
>> Dianne Reeves: And
because he knew who I was,
he knew that she's a live performer.
He understood that.
And someone who is a studio
performer it's a totally
different thing.
But he understood that we have to
get this when she comes in here,
and she's ready and can't
wait to get it down, bam!
And generally, it would be the
first or second take of a song.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
As a live performer,
do you enjoy having
people in the studio
with you, like friends and -- ?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah,
I really, really do.
I need it.
Just -- and not for
applause, just for energy.
I like having that.
The first live record that I did,
we did it at SIR Studios
in Los Angeles.
It was really incredible.
We did it for two nights,
just invited people to come in
and that was just a larger
experience of what I experienced
when I'm doing my records, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Let's take a
step back [inaudible] a little bit.
I want you to think
about all the songs
that you recorded,
all your recordings.
And you think about the
trajectory of your career.
What is the story of your
career in those songs?
>> Dianne Reeves: I think the
biggest story is that I've never had
to compromise and that in the
very beginning I kind of decided
that that's what success was
for me because I was asked --
told that you need to define
what success means to you.
And so for me, music is interesting.
Music saved my life.
And --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
What makes you say that?
>> Dianne Reeves: It
literally saved my life.
Coming up in junior high school,
I was a very depressed
kid, very, very depressed.
>> Larry Appelbaum: In Denver?
>> Dianne Reeves: In Denver.
And just for a lot of reasons that
I won't go into but extremely.
And --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Were you a loner?
>> Dianne Reeves: I've never
been not so much a loner,
but I've never been one
to have lots of people,
only people that I really knew
and it was a small group of people
that to this day we're
still friends.
And I was tall for my age.
I always got criticized about that.
My mother would say oh no, you're
statuesque, and I loved that word.
And just saw things and felt
things in a different kind of way
that was different than my peers.
And I had a situation where
-- when I was 12 years old,
I was found under the steps and
never really talked about this.
I was found under the steps
because I tried to commit suicide.
And I remember I was
out for three days.
The only time that
I looked up was once
to see my mother looking down at me.
And then through the whole process
of they put you with therapists
and stuff, and I wouldn't -- I
would -- I could not talk to them.
And I guess they said we
have to find another way.
But at the same time, had
this really great teacher,
Benny Williams, who was the
choral teacher at our school.
And the other thing was we were
the first kids to be bussed
to the school, Hamilton Junior High.
And --
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
this is like early 70's?
Yeah.
>> Dianne Reeves: Late
60's, early 70's.
And I remember she -- to
bring the students together
because she was the music
teacher, she said I'm going
to bring all this contemporary
music that is happening together
and these kids are going
to sing each other's songs.
So we're singing Bob Dillon's songs.
Black kids were singing
Bob Dillon songs.
White kids were singing
Ball of Confusion.
It was just like she mixed
us up and gave us poetry,
and we wrote our own show.
And it was very empowering.
And I had two songs that I
was singing, one with a group,
another song that came out
on the Edwin Hawkins album
that was Oh Happy Day.
There was a song called Joy.
And that song was my
first song that I sang
that I felt something pull my
heart, and when I closed my eyes,
I started to sing it, and something
that connected with people.
And it was really, really powerful.
And it saved my life.
And I remember walking down the hall
because my grandmother would
always say don't put all your eggs
in one basket, but
this felt so right.
I remember saying out loud,
"I'm putting all my eggs
in one basket" walking
past the science room.
I can see it as vividly
as when it happened.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
that basket is the world
of music and creativity?
>> Dianne Reeves: That
basket was creativity,
the way that I saw what it would
do for me, how it would help me
and its really, really
served in a lot of ways
to change a lot of
things in my life.
People looked at me in
a different kind of way.
And then it became a
place to hide behind.
And I started to realize that
there was Dianne Reeves the artist,
Dianne Reeves the person, and they
really needed to come together
and that's when I did the
Art and Survival album.
And that album was when
everything changed,
and it was like it was very
cathartic for me and it was a record
that wasn't very well received
but those who hear it get it.
It was controversial.
There were a lot of things, and
it was at a crossroads in my life
when I was not with Blue
Note, and I was with --
on the other side of the label
trying to get back to Blue Note
and Bruce -- it's like
a whole bunch of --
there's a whole big story there.
But basically it was the thing that
pushed me through, and it pushed me
through because it was what I wanted
to do no matter what happened.
I would suffer whatever
the consequences.
And I came up on the other
side still there and still able
and still being able to sing
the music I wanted to sing.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Have
your feelings about music
and creativity changed
over the years since then?
>> Dianne Reeves: I think
there are certain things.
I think --
>> Larry Appelbaum: For
example, do you ever get jaded
by the business of music?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, yes but
I kind of -- while I was in it,
I never really was of it.
I don't know how to describe that.
I always marched to my own
drum, and figured people --
I didn't sell a lot of records,
but people come to my concerts.
And nobody could really touch that.
I know people sign deals now
where all that's included.
But that's mine.
I built that.
And so that part was the thing
that allowed me to say well,
I've seen people feel like
they've been thrown --
that they were thrown
away by record companies
because they weren't selling enough
records and I thought to myself,
I never sell enough records.
But I'm still here.
And I'm still doing
what I love to do
and it still takes
care of my life now.
The other side of it is that
I still love to do what I do,
but I know that it's taken away.
I'm not married.
I have no children.
I think about that sometimes,
but I also know about me
that if that's what I chose
to do, I would have done it.
>> Larry Appelbaum: There's
a world outside of music.
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Maybe
not outside of creativity
because that's in everything.
What do you like to
do outside of music?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, I really
love improvising with food.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Really?
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh yeah.
I love to cook.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You're a foodie.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
We travel.
People are always introducing
us to new things
and there are flavors
that I haven't had.
I'll try it and I'll
say what is that?
Why does it taste this
way or whatever?
>> Larry Appelbaum: What's
your latest obsession?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, lately
actually I've just been home
and just eating very,
very, very clean.
I like this whole idea of making
breads out of cauliflower,
figuring out all of
those kinds of things.
But we've been traveling
a great deal.
So I will be in the kitchen
this summer because I'm off.
But basically it's like these
really clean kind of dishes
that there's a place at home
called The True Food Kitchen.
I think they have them
different places.
And it's a pretty cool place.
The way they make the
food taste is good,
but I'm like I can make it better.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
You can [inaudible].
I know you can.
>> Dianne Reeves: But I like
the idea of having tthis food
that is really, really clean
and done in a certain way
that you eat it and you actually
feel energized and good about it.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I know
you travel all over the world.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is there part of
the world you haven't been to yet?
>> Dianne Reeves: I've
never been to India.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do
you like Indian food?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
As a matter of fact, I'm
going tomorrow tonight.
A friend of mine was telling me
about a restaurant so we'll go.
But I love Indian food.
I've never been -- I've been to
lots of places, few places in Africa
but I've never been to Ghana.
We are going to Kenya next year.
And I've never been to Egypt.
So there are a lot of -- and
I've really explored a lot
of South America.
So there are a lot of places.
And the odd thing about
that is there's a lot
of influence in my music from --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Oh, very much so.
>> Dianne Reeves: So I've never --
and that's just from the musicians
that brought the flavor to me.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You and I
are basically same generation,
and I think when we were
coming up and forming some
of our musical taste,
there was a term,
a marketing term called world music.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And
so is that still a thing?
>> Dianne Reeves: I don't know.
I think now it's global.
Now it's just global.
Everybody works with everybody
and goes -- it's just --
the internet has allowed us
to make the world smaller
and more accessible.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do
you stream yourself?
Do you look at Youtube?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah, all of that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is there --
what do you think of the newer
generation of neo soul singers?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well,
I don't know.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Because you
could do that if you wanted.
>> Dianne Reeves: I don't think
they even call themselves neo soul.
But they -- it's like all
of these Indie musicians
and there's this whole
-- and a lot of them come
out of the hip hop generation.
And that's a whole another way
of listening to things that --
I'm still on the outside looking in.
I still -- I love it.
I don't know how they
get to it, some of it.
But I really, really love that it's
new and it's fresh and it's musical
and it's rhythmic and
it expresses poetry
in a totally different kind of way.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I would
imagine that when you were coming up
and started to make your records
people felt the same way about you.
>> Dianne Reeves: Probably.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
there's a continuum?
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh
yeah, absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Each
generation discovers.
>> Dianne Reeves: Oh God, I'm out.
But it's cool because I appreciate
it and I'm surrounded by people
and musicians that appreciated that.
Always still, you look
at people like Herbie
and Wayne always still
pushing to be --
to understand and be
in the relevant flow.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is
recognition important to you?
>> Dianne Reeves: It's cool.
I like that I'm -- in terms of
being able to go out and perform
and other people understand
my work and love it, yeah.
It's very important.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Do you
work as much as you want?
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes, and
I'm off as much as I want.
So that's good.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
That's a nice balance.
>> Dianne Reeves: And
that's what it is right now.
It's all about balance.
>> Larry Appelbaum: What's --
oh I should probably ask you.
Your last recording won a Grammy.
>> Dianne Reeves: Right, right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So
what's the next one?
How do you follow up on a Grammy?
>> Dianne Reeves: A Grammy is
something that happens then
and you're thankful for
it, and you move forward.
And not everything gets
a Grammy or a nomination,
but that's not why you do it.
I have a project that I
just did in [inaudible].
It's a live record which I'm really
excited about that I produced,
and I love it because it is
really just one performance.
It's no mixing of other
performances.
We went in.
We hit it and we have special
guest, [inaudible] on the recording
with my band, Peter Martin,
Reginald Veal, [inaudible]
and [inaudible] on drums.
And we add some new things,
and some things from --
a couple of things from Beautiful
Life, but it's a whole other kind
of feeling and it's very
joyous, and I'm excited about it.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So speaking
of balance, how do you --
how do you balance being the
artist and also being the producer
where you have to sort of be
detached and make decisions?
>> Dianne Reeves: Well, I
had to do a lot of thinking
about how I wanted
it to be presented.
And presented in a way that
my musicians didn't feel
like they were really being recorded
and that I didn't feel like --
that I had to tell myself this
is a live recording and you know
that this is the only one
we're going to do so --
but I just had to spend
time and say you know,
I'm not going to over sing, I'm just
going to do my thing and the way
that I did that was did several
group gigs ahead of time on the way
to doing this last gig and
basically it's just all the work,
the prep work before and it came
out just the way I wanted
it to or actually better.
>> Larry Appelbaum: We're
looking forward to it.
>> Dianne Reeves: Thank you.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is there a
dream project you have in mind
that you haven't done yet?
>> Dianne Reeves: I found a lot
of my dreams have come true.
Some haven't.
But I found that the things that
I could never even think about --
never even thought
about that have come
into my life have been
extraordinary.
So I'm just open.
>> Larry Appelbaum: How about
somebody you haven't worked with
yet that you've always wanted to.
>> Dianne Reeves: Some of
those people have passed
on so that's not going
to happen, but no.
I'm just open.
When we did the Sing the
Truth project with [inaudible]
and Liz Wright, it was something
that came up, that's a good idea.
Now we fill in the blanks and make
it and we celebrated Nina Simone,
and it was an extraordinary
experience
with Nina Simone's daughter, Simone.
And it was really, really great.
And it wasn't anything
I thought of doing.
But I'm glad that we did.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I would
bet that there are musicians
out there whose dream is
to do something with you.
>> Dianne Reeves: I'm open.
Yeah, and they call me.
I just did this think
with [inaudible].
He has this new project [inaudible]
coming out, and it was really kind
of cool because he had me singing.
He called me up.
He says, "Do you think
you would sing --
learn the lyrics in [inaudible]?"
I was like really?
And so right when I know
that I'm going to say no,
I grit my teeth and say yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Because just pushing on.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah because
it's going to be interesting.
I have the time.
I can -- I said look, I need you
to do this, this, this and this.
He said okay, and it
was extraordinary.
Had so much fun.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did you
listen to him teach you the lyric
or did he write it out phonetically?
>> Dianne Reeves: He wrote it for me
phonetically -- no, he wrote it out.
Just like I wrote it phonetically, I
had him speak the words and send it
to me and then I just
went line by line.
It wasn't a whole lot but
it's tonal and rhythmic.
And some of the rhythm I was not --
I was like I don't
even know where one is.
Still don't, but I realize
learn it like a kindergartner
like you just don't care about that.
It just is, and I did, and
I had so much fun with it.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
It's also connecting
to the real source of music.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And that's
where it all comes fromj.
>> Dianne Reeves: Yeah, absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Dianne Reeves: So cool.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Dianne, it's
always a pleasure to talk to you.
We're looking forward to
your performance tonight.
Continued success.
>> Dianne Reeves: Thank
you very much.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And all that's to come.
>> Dianne Reeves: Thank you so much.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Thank you.
>> Dianne Reeves: All right.
This was good.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.